pop des limites
résumé des épisodes précédents
la princesse mais dynamique et le prince
menu durent attendre le mercredi pour
retrouver leur tendance normale
quelle ne fut pas leur choix thomas ton
assiette moi ton assiette conquête
elle n'est pas prête pas vraiment eh ben
tu sembles tout cas je peux te dire que
je suis rassuré parce que c'est mon avis
je suis plus à l'aise comme ça - avec
l'imam les apparences et ont comme ça où
on allait justement aller moi aussi
personnellement une vivacité bien
contente aussi d'être un garçon est ce
que ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir le
psychologue
oui non mais tu te vois que reste quand
même en gardant est naturelle et
attendue mais tu sais ce qui se passe on
a donné à réfléchir je me suis dit tiens
nadine pourquoi je serai pas tout aussi
libéré un gilet la chanson je la connais
libérez libérez les jambes délibérée de
faire comme signal de trois selles dans
ma combien cela quoi de te dire quelque
chose
maintenant on ce mardi dans un an deux
ans d'accord on a un enfant
ton père il faut bien garder le coach et
un soir sur deux et nous en sort on est
libéré il n'y a pas que ça
financièrement je vais te verrai la
crise elles sont surtout très belle
étape et sont pas financièrement les
finances tu veux dire aux français ont
tendance à n'a pas besoin de travailler
votre parcours
c'est pas tout grâce aux grosses
chaleurs
fascicolo quand tu me rappelles aïcha
écrasé que j'ai bien connue et je sais
comment il a fini c'était celle aïcha
travailler un jour je te parlerai 2 1
non à l'union revient des choses
sérieuses julie fuchs départ bon bon bon
bon un délicieux regarde où je te dire
je te crois que j'ai trouvé du travail
au frère manu tortionnaires travail bien
payé
mi-temps se présenter chez le marquis de
sade tous les samedis manutentionnaire
tu vas savoir faire le manutentionnaire
toi j'ai parce que c'est lui mais ça va
rien marques pas tu sais qui c'est alizé
compris tu mon père de tronçons et les
fiers et les fiers
[Musique]